PLEASURE TO JOIN YOU AND NOW
HERE'S TUCKER CARLSON.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WOUND UP IN A VERY
PUBLIC BRAWL TODAY WITH A MAN
WHO WAS ONCE ONE OF HIS CLOSEST
EFFORT, AND FOR THE FIRST
GOVERNMENTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION UNTIL AUGUST, HE
WAS ONE OF THE TOP STAFFERS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOW HE APPEARS TO BE AT ODDS
WITH HIS FORMER BOSS, TO PUT IT
MILDLY.
IN AN UPCOMING BOOK, BANNON IS
QUOTED AS SAYING THAT A MEETING
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
ITS OFFICIALS AND THE RUSSIAN
LAWYER BACK IN 2015 MAY HAVE
IMMEDIATELY WITH THE STATEMENT
AS PUNGENT AS IT WAS DIRECT.
"STEVE BANNON HAS NOTHING TO DO
LOST HIS JOB, HE LOST HIS MIND.
STEVE WAS A STAFFER WHO WORKED
FOR ME AFTER I HAD ALREADY WON
THE NOMINATION BY DEFEATING 17
CANDIDATES.
NOW THAT HE'S ON HIS OWN, STEVE
IS LEARNING THAT WINNING IS NOT
AS EASY AS I MAKE IT LOOK.
STEVE HAD VERY LITTLE TO DO WITH
OUR HISTORIC VICTORY, WHICH WAS
DELIVERED BY THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY, YET
STEVE HAD EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
THE LOSS OF A SENATE SEAT IN
ALABAMA HELD FOR MORE THAN 30
YEARS BY REPUBLICANS.
STEVE DOES NOT REPORT THAT MY
BASE, HE'S ONLY IN IT FOR
HIMSELF.
WE HAVE MANY GREAT REPUBLICAN
NUMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
CANDIDATES WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THEM MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
AGENDA.
LIKE ME, THEY LOVE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND ARE
HELPING TO FINALLY TAKE OUR
COUNTRY BACK AND BUILD IT UP
RATHER THAN SIMPLY SEEKING TO
MORE THAN ALL DOWN."
PRETTY AMUSING.
OBSCURE THE LARGER TRUTH.
IF THE IDEOLOGICAL GULF BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND STEVE BANNON
THIS IS NOT A FIGHT OVER IDEAS,
IT'S A FIGHT OVER WHO DESERVES
CREDIT FOR AN ELECTION WIN.
TALK ABOUT MISSING THE POINT.
IF THE LEGACY OF 2016 IS NOT A
SINGLE PERSON, ANY PERSON, IT'S
NEEDS AND THE FEARS AND THE
ASPIRATIONS OF A BADLY
MISTREATED AMERICAN MIDDLE-CLASS
MISTREATED AMERICAN MIDDLE-CLAS
MIDDLE-CLASS.
THOSE VOTERS CAME TO THE POLLS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED REAL
BORDERS, HIGHER WAGES, THEY WERE
DISPIRITED BY THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC, WHY WOULDN'T THEY BE.
THEY WERE SICK OF BEING LECTURED
BY POLITICAL CLASS OF WASHINGTON
THAT DESPISES THEM AND HOLDS
THEM IN CONTEMPT.
THEY WERE THE OTHER COUNTRY, BUT
THEY HAD COME TO RECOGNIZE THAT
IT IS HARD TO MAKE THE REST OF
THE WORLD BETTER AND VERY EASY
TO MAKE IT WORSE.
ABOVE ALL, THEY VOTED FOR
LEADERSHIP THAT PROMISED TO PUT
AMERICANS FIRST ABOVE ANY
FOREIGN NATION OR DOMESTIC
INTEREST GROUP.
THAT IS THE REAL LEGACY OF 2016.
AT THAT AGENDA.
REGARDLESS OF WHO STAFFS IT.
MATCH LAP IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HE JOINS US TONIGHT, GOOD TO SEY
HE JOINS US TONIGHT, GOOD TO SEU
HE JOINS US TONIGHT, GOOD TO SE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE HAD A LOT OF DIFFERENT LEAD
SEGMENTS IN MIND BECAUSE THERE'S
A LOT GOING ON.
WASHINGTON AND I'M STILL TRYING
ALL THESE HOURS LATER TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
WHO'S SERVED BY THIS ARGUMENT
AND WHAT DOES IT REPRESENT.
>> I THINK THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT
ARE PROSECUTING THE CASE AGAINST
WHO WAS A LEGITIMATELY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
RESISTANCE AND ALL THE FORCES
THAT FEEL A LITTLE WIND IN THEIR
SAILS BECAUSE OF THIS STATEMENT
FROM STEVE BANNON, WHICH IS OVER
THE LINE, INAPPROPRIATE AND HE
REALLY SHOULD TAKE IT BACK
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE WHAT HE SAID.
>> Tucker: WHICH STATEMENT ARE
YOU REFERRING TO?
>> THE IDEA THAT JARED KUSHNER
OR DON JR. ARE TRAITORS OR ACTED
IN A TREASONOUS WAY.
THE PALE AND HE OUGHT TO TAKE IT
BACK.
THAT'S REALLY NOT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT, BECAUSE WHAT HE SAID
EARLIER IS THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION WAS A CANARD, THAT
THERE WAS NO RUSH OR COLLUSION,
THAT HE SAW NOTHING
INAPPROPRIATE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHO ARE
GOOD-NATURED AND FAIR, ARE GOING
TO COME DOWN ON THIS WHOLE SET
OF QUESTIONS AND THIS WILL BE A
DRAMA THAT WE WILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH OVER THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS.
BUT I THINK IT'S A VERY
UNFORTUNATE THING.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU GET FOR
THE BOTTOM OF THE PRESIDENT'S
STATEMENT I'M A VERY COLORFUL
STATEMENT, HE SAYS THIS.
STEVE DOESN'T REPRESENT MY BASE,
HE'S ONLY IN IT FOR HIMSELF.
THAT SEEMS LIKE THE NUB OF IT
IS THAT THE PRESIDENT OR IS IT
HIS CHIEF STRATEGIST STEVE
>> THE CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT IS
NOT ALIGNED TO ANY ONE PERSON,
BUT THEY ARE HEAD OVER HEELS
TRUMP AGENDA.
THEY KNOW THAT WE COULD BE
KNOW THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE A
HUGE ELECTION AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR WHERE THE MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE ARE UP FOR
GRABS.
AND THEY BELIEVE -- THEY MIGHT
HAVE BEEN UNSURE ABOUT TRUMP IN
THE BEGINNING BUT THEY ARE NOT
ALLEGIANCES WITH, IT'S THE
LEADER OF THEIR PARTY.
IF THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES AND ITS THE AGENDA
HE'S PUSHING.
AND STEVE BANNON'S FOR THAT
AGENDA TOO.
SO WHY DO ANYTHING TO HELP
TRUMP, AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
STEVE MADE A BIG MISTAKE WITH
HIS TALKING TO A VERY LEFT-WING
>> Tucker: THAT JOURNALIST IS
NOT VERY LEFT WING, BY THE WAY.
THE POINT OF FACT.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
JOURNALIST IS SOMEBODY WHO HE
SHOULD TALK TO IN THIS MANNER IN
ORDER TO REALLY TRY TO HARM THE
TRUMP AGENDA.
I DON'T THINK IT'S SMART.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT SAYING
THAT, I'M JUST SAYING I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THAT JOURNALIST,
BECAUSE I THINK IS AN HONEST
JOURNALIST.
>> I DON'T THINK HE HAS AN
IDEOLOGICAL AGENDA HERE.
WHAT I'M STRUCK BY IS THE FACT
>> I THINK THE POINT OF THIS IS
WHEN YOU ARE A STAFFER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, YOU ARE A STAFFER.
BY THE WAY, HE DID THIS AS A
STAFFER.
IF YOU SERVE A PRESIDENT, I
SERVED A PRESIDENT, RIGHT, AND
YOU DON'T TALK TO JOURNALIST
WITH HER ON THE RECORD OR OFF
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Tucker: I'M JUST SAYING.
IN FIVE DIFFERENT INTERVIEWS IN
TRUMP BY BANNON OR ATTACKS THAT
CLEARLY CAME FROM BANNON AND I'M
JUST WONDERING IS THERE A POINT,
THE INSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT IN WASHINGTON.
>> I THINK STEVE BANNON IS AN
BECAUSE THIS LOOKS PERSONAL,
IT'S ABOUT REVISION AND IT HELPS
THE LEFT.
I THINK ACTIVISTS AROUND THIS
COUNTRY, CONSERVATIVE ACTIVISTS
AGENDA.
ANYTHING THAT GETS IN THE WAY OF
THAT AGENDA, CERTAINLY WHEN IT'S
ABOUT EGO CLAIMING CREDIT AS A
DESTROYER'S DISTRACTION.
I THINK HE HURTS HIMSELF UNLESS
HE COMES OUT AND SAYS LOOK I
MIGHT HAVE DISAGREEMENTS WITH
JARED KUSHNER OR
DONALD TRUMP JR., BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING TO THIS
>> Tucker: VERY QUICKLY, THERE
PRESIDENT IN 2020, IS THAT TRUE,
DOES HE HAVE A SHOT DO YOU THINK
DOES HE HAVE A SHOT DO YOU THIN
THINK?
>> HE DOES NOT HAVE A SHOT,
PERIOD, AND HE CERTAINLY DOESN'T
HAVE A SHOT OF THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
NO ONE WILL RUN TO THE RIGHT OF
DONALD TRUMP.
HE HAS CAPTURED THAT BY MAKING
HIS COMMITMENT TO CONSERVATIVES